So we've been we've been following Donald
Trump's recovery from Corona virus.
It's been a very up and down, erratic period
with various completely unbelievable and deceptive
claims from Donald Trump's doctor and Donald
Trump triumphantly returning to the White
House and then gasping for air visibly.
Well, we've been tracking it all.
We know Donald Trump has received a variety
of different medications.
And we've also observed this week Donald Trump
has again gone back to doing rallies this
week.
And we've observed that in the evenings at
the rallies, Trump seems hopped up.
And I mean that colloquially he's speaking
very, very quickly.
He's more red.
And I think this is even accounting for the
makeup.
He's more red and sort of sweaty than we typically
see.
And the speculation, of course, is that he
is still either receiving steroids as part
of his treatment, which are kind of giving
him this energy, or possibly he's being given
a steroid, like to suppress a cough and to
energize him because he is still potentially
struggling with the effects of coronavirus.
As we know from the millions of cases of corona
virus that we've now seen, sometimes you'll
have this five to seven day period and you'll
be feeling better, and then later you'll be
feeling worse.
And it can be tough to shake it sometimes
even for months, particularly for folks in
their 70s and 80s, as Donald Trump is.
Well, yesterday we had a Trump event earlier
in the day for the first time in a while.
Donald Trump's events have tended to be in
the evenings earlier in the day yesterday.
Donald Trump apparently not juiced up and
his voice was completely failing, suggesting
he is really not doing as well as he would
like us to think.
And of course, with Corona virus, it could
go any way at any time in terms of a return
to more serious symptoms.
So take a look at this first clip.
This is from an event Trump did.
He was in the Rose Garden and he was speaking
via teleconference to a number of different
economic clubs, the New York Economic Club.
I think a couple of others and Trump just
really struggling here, take a look at this.
Simply put, it's a choice between a socialist
nightmare and the American dream.
And this continued throughout the entire event.
Here's another one of these just pausing,
struggling to speak, having to catch his breath.
Clearing throat, cough, etc., instead of corrupt
and horrendous trade deals written by lobbyists
and special interests.
And some of you, I negotiated pro American
trade deals based on the principles of fairness
and reciprocity.
Very important.
I ended the NAFTA nightmare and signed the
brand new U.S., Mexico Canada agreement into
law.
I've taken the toughest ever action against
China's chronic great abuses that we all know
so well.
Really sounding terrible.
And of course, this is naturally, you know,
he's 74 and he had Corona virus a week ago,
causing speculation to run rampant about.
Is Trump contagious?
How serious is Trump's case?
What are the symptoms he's having?
Should he really be doing these rallies now?
Of course, sounding like that doesn't mean
you're contagious.
Sounding like that doesn't even mean it's
not even necessarily because of coronavirus.
People get coughs and difficulty speaking
from non corona virus of viruses and conditions
as well.
But it does raise questions about just how
well Donald Trump is doing.
Now, also, during this event, Trump referred.
It wasn't just how he sounded.
The things he said also were extremely disturbing.
Trump reference to globalists again.
And that's another one of those words where
we wonder, does Trump know that in many Right-Wing
circles and conspiratorial circles, globalist
is code for crafty Jews, that these are sort
of interchangeable terms?
Or does Trump not have any idea?
We don't know.
But Trump using the term anyway.
The last administration sold out American
workers like never before, and they sold them
to donors, special interests and globalists.
And if you take a look, we have probably plenty
of them watching right now.
And I understand where you're coming from,
but didn't work out too well with me.
So, yeah, that that is a term that has Cygnet
much, much like America first, which sounds
sort of innocuous, but as a very ugly past,
that is a term with an ugly past.
And unclear if Donald Trump knows it, of course,
is.
As far as we know, other people are writing
Donald Trump's speeches.
Hard to tell sometimes whether Trump is ad
libbing or reading off of the prompter.
Who knows?
But Trump continuing to use that term without
really understanding it.
Donald Trump also claimed during this event
that the country, if Joe Biden is elected,
will experience a worse depression than 1929.
Take a listen to this.
Because they will destroy this country.
Our country will go into a depression the
likes of which we have not seen since 1929
and may maybe worse.
So keep back in them.
But, you know, it's wrong.
And I really do believe it's only habit.
That's the only reason you can be doing it
under my continued leadership.
So we've looked at this in depth.
If you watch this show, if you listen to my
podcast, you know that the economy does better
under Democratic presidents than Republicans.
There is no qualitative or quantitative case
to be made that would support a cratering
economy.
If Joe Biden is president and as we talked
about earlier today, even the right wing American
Enterprise Institute says Joe Biden's tax
plan would actually be B, fine for the economy
and the tax hikes would go to the richest
five percent, 95 percent of the country would
get a tax decrease under Joe Biden.
So not based, in fact.
Donald Trump continuing to use the talking
point that he saved two million lives by whatever
it is he did on coronavirus other.
If it weren't for Trump, he wants you to believe.
Two point two million people would have died.
Take a look.
Our aggressive and early actions saved up
to two million lives.
If you look at the original numbers, it was
projected at two point two million lives.
We're at two hundred and ten thousand and
one is too many.
It should have never happened.
Should have never been allowed to happen by
China.
Thanks to advances in treatment.
So I almost don't want to do this, but I think
I should do it.
This is the way that the numbers go up.
First, Donald Trump said we had fifteen cases
and they would soon be zero.
Donald Trump then said we were going to keep
the death toll under 50000, then under 60000
thousand once it got to 70.
He said it would be under 100 once it got
to 100 times.
Trump said it would be under 200.
Once it became clear it would be more than
200 now.
Donald Trump is saying, listen, two point
two million people could have died.
So that's the number if literally no one does
anything.
And remember, even if Trump did nothing, as
he did nothing initially, governors were still
going to do things.
So this idea of two point two million deaths
is ridiculous.
But.
Here's where the number comes from.
Three hundred and thirty one million people
live in the United States.
If you assume no measures whatsoever until
there is herd immunity, it just spreads.
That would suggest about 70 percent of the
country would get the virus.
At that point, you would have achieved herd
immunity.
So 70 percent of 331 million is about 231
million people with a one percent death rate
or just below one percent death rate.
If you do nothing and 70 percent of the country
gets infected, you would expect somewhere
between two point one and two point three
million people to die.
But again, that is doing nothing.
That's every other country does stuff and
we do nothing.
No governors do anything.
No masks.
Trump does nothing.
It's a crazy comparison.
It's laughable and idiotic to still be mentioning
it, but because we went from zero deaths to
fifty thousand sixty seventy eighty one hundred
two hundred now two hundred and twenty thousand
or more.
Donald Trump now has to say, well, listen,
we could have lost two point two million people.
I don't think Trump would have survived a
situation in which the death toll was going
to be two point two million.
But that's a story probably for a different
day.
We'll continue discussing this on The David
Pakman Show Instagram David Pakman show.
And while you are on Instagram, follow me
at David Dot Packman.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.